hi
and welcome to the session software
defined network image hpc
in this session we'll discuss how cloud
networking and sdn enables customers to
run hpc application scale on google
cloud high performance computing is a
foundational infrastructure for
researchers and scientists for their
computational needs
and hbc's importance is actually much
more evident during these times like the
kovid 19 panel
for example scientists in the life
sciences industry are seeing sudden
demand for the computing needs
and are increasingly turning towards
cloud technologies for their
computational needs
we are also observing the same trend
of demand i mean in other areas of hbc
like financial modeling
and weather forecasting
hpc infrastructure can be quite complex
and require highly specialized and very
expensive infrastructure
with the advent of cloud computing more
and more customers are
advancing the flexibility and agility of
the cloud model for their hpc
applications
so the good news is that hpc workloads
can leverage cloud and cloud can deliver
the comparable a comparable
or better performance metrics for most
hpc workloads
this code from andrew sutherland of mit
sums it up quite well
how cloud computing can help their hpc
application
to do a much better job with hpc
in this presentation today i will share
how google cloud can help your hpc
application run in cloud and provide the
best experience
and meet your price performance
objectives my name is manoj i'm a
product manager in google cloud
networking team and i will be
co-presenting this session
so this talk is primarily focused on
networking aspects of hpc
but we'll also be discussing about other
components of the infrastructure and
services that's required to run hpc in
the cloud
we will talk about some specifications
specific application benchmarks that
provide insights into the capabilities
of google cloud
google cloud offers the best class
infrastructure to run hpc applications
our offerings provide a broad set of
compute products around tightly coupled
and parallel workloads
including machine learning applications
and high performance data analytics
workloads
these products are actually backed by
google networking and google's
networking is the same networking that
is built and designed to run
all of google's billion plus usage
services the services like gmail
services like maps services like search
everything runs on the same
infrastructure as google cloud we'll be
discussing this in a lot more details in
our next couple of
slides google cloud platform also
provides a very broad set of storage
applications that helps you deploy hpc
applications that scale on google cloud
we'll be talking a lot more about that
in this session as well
last but not least we have a very broad
ecosystem of
partners that helps us fill the gaps
that we may have in google cloud
specifically when you look at the stack
for hpc exactly quite deep
so things like schedulers and workload
managers we have a strong
partner ecosystem that helps you fill
that those gaps
our success in hpc is very evident in
the broad set of successful deployments
that we have across different verticals
like healthcare life sciences financial
services educational research etc
they run complex hpc cores like
computational fluid dynamics and weather
modeling with great success on dual
cloud and very very high scales
this list is actually growing
tremendously
as i mentioned before we have a very
strong set of ecosystem partners
as i mentioned hpc is not just
infrastructure it actually has the
stack that is very very deep so we have
a very broad set of partner ecosystems
that help you fill the gaps
that you might actually have on google
home for example
workload managers and schedulers and
system integration
so that actually helps customers to very
quickly come onto cloud and deploy their
applications
as fast as they can now let's go
and have a very deep journey into the
networking stack of google cloud
in the next few slides we will show you
how google cloud uses
the power of software defined networking
to deliver
high performance and low latency on a
general purpose multi-tenant
cloud infrastructure gcp supports up to
100 gbps of bandwidth
on a single vm and delivers latency as
low as 10 microseconds
between two vms in the same placement
policy group
so let's get started google was one of
the pioneers of software defined
networking for both physical networks
and virtual networks google's virtual
networking
sdn stack is called andromeda
a key aspect of the sdn architecture
is the separation of the control plane
from its data plane
the data plane resides in physical
switches for example the
edge routers in a data center and
virtual switches like the
hypervisor on every machine in the cloud
a logically centralized control plane
has a complete view of the network
as well as the customer intent the
controller then realizes customer intent
across different data plane elements
for example the andromeda controller
shown here in this picture
takes a vpc firewall policy translates
it into appropriate rules for
each host that's running a vm for that
vpc
and then distributes that policy to the
virtual switches
on those machines an important benefit
of this architecture is that it scales
better
and removes the bottlenecks found in
traditional networking
for example it lets us provide the same
vpc features to vms
bare metal instances and containers
the feature that is most relevant to
high performance computing
is performance and in particular the
performance of the virtual switch that
implements
most of cloud networking's routing and
security policies
so how does google build a fast virtual
switch
the andromeda virtual switch is built
using a framework called snap
snap enables os bypass packet processing
pipelines in user mode
snap supports running these pipelines on
dedicated threads
or in shared threads andromeda on snap
has two key components a fast path
and per vm coprocessors the first
path packet pipeline runs on dedicated
threads
and it has a very small cpu budget
literally
nanoseconds for every packet more
expensive pipelines such as nat
and dos protection they run in per vm
coprocessors so this architecture neatly
enables us to achieve both high
performance
and isolation that is one vm's traffic
does not affect another vm
software tuning such as dedicated
threads and
optimizing the number of instructions
per packet you know
can only take you so far to get true
hpc class performance hardware offloads
have typically played a critical role
andromeda started out its offload uh
efforts with simpler offloads such as
tcp segmentation and send receive
offloads
we then added encryption offload to it
as it was one of the expensive
components
of our packet processing pipeline a
recent enhancement which is very
relevant to hpc
is the introduction of zero copy payload
transfers
between a vm's memory and the nic
hardware
andromeda still gets to process headers
of packets
and hence it can continue to enforce vpc
policies
and rate limits but there is no software
involved in the movement of payload
which helps us achieve higher
performance
so now let's see how well it works in
practice or what performance we are able
to achieve
this graph here shows how performance
has been a big focus
of google cloud networking for for many
years and we've been making continuous
improvements
in performance only the last two bars of
this graph are relevant to
current skus we're able to hit a line
rate of 100 gbps
inside your vms and this is available
right now
on gpu attached vms other types of vms
have up to 32 gbps depending on the core
count
so with that we've solved the bandwidth
problem
what about the harder problem of latency
which is also very critical to hpc
workloads
for latency the entire software stack
as well as the network connecting the
vms play a critical role
we've looked at the virtual switch in
the hypervisor htcp
now let's take a look at what's inside
the guest vm
and and the rest of the hpc stack
in this figure starting at the very top
are the applications
tightly coupled mpi applications
are written to mpi frameworks and gcp
supports both
intel mpi and openmpi
these frameworks depend on either
directly the linux
tcpip stack or they access the
networking stack
through libraries like the lift fabric
library now google
has invented many of the major
improvements to tcp
uh in the last few years and we have one
of the best congestion control teams in
the world
underneath the tcp stack are the drivers
that interact
with the virtualized nic gcp supports
the generic
word io driver but recently we also
introduced our own google virtual nic
driver this gvnic device exposes the
best of google's infrastructure to the
guest os
for example the zero copy feature that i
talked about
is exposed by the juvenile driver
now google has one of the best
performing sdn based physical networks
underneath google cloud but no matter
how good the network
is one of the important things you can
do to reduce latency is really
place vms next to each other this is
where the placement policy comes in
gcp supports two types of placement
policies
compact and spread vms
associated with the same compact
placement policy are placed
very close to each other in the data
center
so now let's see how well all this works
in practice
the graph here shows
an experiment where we run the famous
mpi
ping pong benchmark on google cloud
the leftmost data point is the baseline
latency between two vms
without any placement policy and as you
can see here we
get about 28 microseconds
by choosing the right vm type in this
case
the compute optimized vms that manoj
will talk about in a bit
and associating them with a compact
placement policy
we were able to get the latency down to
18 microseconds
so that's a good 10 microsecond
improvement on the base latency
in a zone as we tuned different layers
of the stack that i showed
in in the last few slides we see that
latency continued to improve
and you know the bottom line is that we
can get
to under 10 microsecond latency on
google cloud today
which is sufficient for running some of
the most demanding workloads
now we don't expect our customers to
make all these optimizations by hand
so we've created solutions guide as well
as batch script
that you can run inside your favorite vm
instance types
to uh to activate these optimizations
so that gives you a flavor of how gcp
leverages sdn to build the right network
for hpc
this sdn enabled network gives you low
latency
and high throughput your mpi traffic can
leverage vpc features like the vpc
firewall
and since all this is built via software
on general purpose infrastructure high
performance networking is available
on many instance types both general
purpose
as well as compute optimized vms
now let's take a look at compute and
storage
infrastructure now that we understand a
little bit more about the networking
magic
uh that connects everything together
let's talk a little bit more about what
other components of the infrastructure
is required to make a hpci application
successful in google cloud
google cloud actually offers a broad set
of compute products
that can suit all kinds of applications
starting from web servers to
network appliances and of course large
scale tightly coupled mpi and nickel
workloads
the general purpose instances called the
n2 series or into or into d machines
they actually balance price and
performance that are suitable for most
workloads that you may have
but we have specialized compute
optimized vms called the c2 instances
that offer
high-end bc fuel performance for
for hpc applications we'll talk a little
bit more about the c2 instance type in
the next slide
we also have a memory optimized vm tab
called m2
that is actually suitable for your
memory intensive applications
like sap hana for lower tco app again
tcu is actually very very important for
hpc because as you mentioned before
hpc infrastructure can be quite
expensive so cost is very important for
a lot of customers
so first customers like that we offer
the preemptable vm times
if your applications are designed as a
fault tolerant application
and and can withstand possible
preemptions
then the preemptable instance type can
save up to 80
of your time uh of your savings
we also provide the best accelerator um
actually in cloud including the nvidia
gpus and google innovations like
intensive processing units to speed up
your your your applications and give you
a faster timed results
now let's talk a little bit about the
compute optimized vm or the c2 instance
types
compute optimized vms are well suited
for http application as i said before
both tightly coupled applications and
high throughput applications
compute optimized instances offer
high-end vcpu performance for computer
workloads
and offer up to 40 more performance
compared to your
general purpose vms they also leverage
the second generation intel xeon
processors
and can run at a sustained clock speed
of about 3.8 gigahertz
additionally this is actually a very
important point c2 vms can
provide full transparency to the
architecture of the underlying server
platforms
the numa topology is actually exposed
into the guest operating system
and then applications can actually make
smart choices
to use the newer topology this actually
improves the performance
a lot you can choose a c2 instance
up to 60v cpus and 250 uh 250
gigabytes of memory and attach up to
three terabytes of local storage
c2 instances can also deliver up to 32
gigabytes
uh is 32gbps of bi-directional
throughput today
for the light cpu configuration type and
we have a very strong road map to
basically
improve this and you can actually expect
those high
performance through throughput instances
to be on c2 instances
what we are observing is hpc and machine
learning infrastructure are undergoing a
convergence we are actually seeing more
and more machine learning workloads
now using the hpc platform gpus are
hence becoming a very integral part of
hpc
gcp actually offers high performance
gpus on google cloud for machine
learning central computation
and 3d visualization gpus can actually
be added to your
your vm instance type and these vm
insteads are highly configurable because
it has storage
memory bandwidth and it actually acts
like a a regular vm for you
but you can you can attach up to eight
gpus
for these instance range gps will also
work with your gka clusters
and gpu will always for you will also
work with your preemptable vms
which is actually a very common use case
for hpc and ml
now one very important point that i
would like to make is we have a very
strong partnership with nvidia and that
actually helps us
bring the gpus that the the latest and
the greatest gpus
uh that basically nvidia comes up with
on our class platform as
fast as we can today we support the
tesla platform and uh in the future we
are in the very near future we'll be
supporting the nvidia's actually ampere
platform
uh from a bandwidth standpoint we
actually deliver up to 100 gigs on
certain
gpu types today and this is actually in
beta but we have a very very strong road
map coming up
and you can expect that you know the
higher throughput
um that which is very very important for
hpc is going to be showing up
for the gpu machine types in the very
near future uh now cost is actually very
important for for customers have you
mentioned before right so we have
various programs and various options
that's available for customers
for example with preemptable vm types as
i mentioned before you can actually save
up to 80
of your cost we also offer
strong deep discounts for committed and
sustained uses you could actually save
up 30 to 50
55 depending on how how
long you are using the the vm instances
now let's talk a little bit about the
storage uh support on gcp storage is
also very important it's very complex
and as i mentioned before uh the
requirements for htc applications
actually quite broad
um storage requirements uh for hpc's
they're very similar to what uh
any other regular enterprise application
but with some exceptions right
google cloud platform delivers various
storage offerings uh like sql noise sql
blob and blog and what have you it's a
broad set of offerings
but for we have some some offering that
is very specifically designed for http
for example
we have object stores and file stores
and a 46 compliant
parallel file system that is very widely
used
in the htc space but the very step the
very first step that a customer normally
takes is how do i
move my data from on-premise to google
cloud so for that
we actually offer a service called tsop
customers can use this service to
hydrate their
google cloud storage systems uh from on
premise
gcs or the google cloud storage system
is our
google cloud object store and a lot of
customers actually use this as
primary storage and a lot there are
other other customers
use this for actually archival storage
on google cloud we also have a broad set
of nfs offering
uh both google manage and partner manage
uh file store
um cloud file store is our
um interface file system and
and the capacity that we offer today is
about 60 tb
we have also announced the file store
high scale offering
which can actually scale up to 325
terabytes
customers also have the option to use
emc or
netapp if they choose that as their
option
now hpc customers who are running
tightly coupled applications for mpi
applications they normally require a
posix compliant
parallel file system so gcp has
partnered with a company called ddn
and jointly we basically provide an
offering on google marketplace
where they can actually use luster as
their file system
that help that has very high iops and
scales horizontally for the hpc needs
so to sum it up customers can then
deploy the right storage system for the
later application and the guest
and get the best possible tco now let us
see how all these things come together
uh in our next few slides
so now that we gave you glimpse of the
building blocks needed to build an hpc
solution
we'll take a look at two specific
workloads
the first workload is a weather
forecasting workload
it's a benchmark that many customers run
on premise
on their state-of-the-art dedicated
infiniband clusters
the first line on this graph shows the
performance some customers get
on premise faster completion which is
you know lower value
is better in this case the second line
shows how this workload performed on gcp
without many of the optimizations we
talked about today
once we applied these optimizations that
we discussed
plus some workload specific tuning we
were able to not only match the
performance
the customers get on premise but we did
it
with 30 percent for your cpu cores
now there are additional optimizations
that we've not shown in this graph that
can bring down the completion time
even further but you're not always
shooting for lowest latency but the best
price performance ratio
for your workload and this workload this
benchmark
demonstrates that really well
let's also look at the ls dyna workload
uh this is a well-known workload in the
automotive industry
that does crash simulations this
workload is notoriously tricky to scale
the two graphs here show two different
configurations of this workload
as you can see that with the help of the
optimizations that we discussed today
this workload scales quite well up to
multiple hundreds of cores on gpu on gcp
this is as good as what our customers
are able to get on premise on a
dedicated specialized infrastructure
we've looked at many such workloads we
only discussed
these two and what we find is that for
each workload and a given data set
there is a sweet spot in terms of price
performance ratio
once you have the right set of tools you
can easily find that sweet spot and
provision
and pay for just enough infrastructure
for your workload
and cloud lets you make that trade-off
which was not even possible on premise
so in summary we would like to leave you
uh
with three key messages you know one is
that you no longer need to pay for
a dedicated specialized infrastructure
to run hpc workloads google cloud
makes available to you the best in class
infrastructure
that we use to run our own high
performance
and ai machine learning workloads
anyone can get access to this
infrastructure on demand
and pay only for what they use
number two hpc is a huge area of
investment for us
we built a number of solutions for
various industry verticals
and new ones are being added to it every
day
number three if you don't see your
workload listed here please do
let us know we want to make sure that
google cloud
is the best at running all kinds of high
performance computing
as well as high performance data
analytics workload
thank you thank you